GUOLONG: That is Friday in one
of the classrooms of Building
26, 11:00 AM.
MARZIEH: So I was quite nervous.
SHAWN: The first day is a
little bit nervous for me.
CARLA: I was nervous.
I'm not going to deny it.
NARRATOR: Facing your
students for the first time
can be a little
scary, but it's also
an opportunity to establish
that your class will
be user-friendly.
BILLY: I think the
first day of class
really sets the tone for
the rest of the semester.
NARRATOR: How can you
set the right tone?
As they make their way to your
classroom on the first day,
what qualities are your
students hoping for?
BILLY: Being knowledgeable
and understanding the concept.
ADRIAN: And you need to feel
that you can approach them.
CHANDLER: Have just
an air of confidence.
ADRIAN: Being easy
to understand.
BILLY: And being enthusiastic.
CHANDLER: Being there,
having a presence,
having a lesson plan ready.
CAROL: They're well-organized.
NARRATOR: That may
sound like a lot.
Let's start with
approachability.
ADRIAN: That is important that
you feel accepted and welcomed
in the environment.
NARRATOR: Being
approachable can be
as simple as facing the class
and smiling-- even if you feel
like hiding behind your papers.
And making eye contact.
BILLY: Making eye contact
just is a personal connection
to the person you are talking
to-- the audience in general.
So students feel like the
explanation you are making
is for them.
CAROL: It is an important
form of communication
for them to do that.
It definitely holds the
students' attention.
BILLY: In terms of
international TAs, in general,
there may be some
misunderstanding
here and there, but I think
it's important to make
the students comfortable
asking for the TA
to repeat any word
or any sentence.
CAROL: I think at the
beginning of the semester,
they should maybe say that
it's OK for the students
to ask for clarifications
if something isn't clear.
I think that's generally
a good thing for all TAs
to welcome any questions.
ADRIAN: Show that
you are open and you
care about the success
of the students
that you are trying to teach.
NARRATOR: Enthusiasm
is another way
to show your students your
class will be friendly.
BILLY: Being enthusiastic and
showing that you're actually
passionate about
the material you
are teaching-- that also gives
a little more comfortable
atmosphere during recitation.
CAROL: I think TAs who are
excited about what they're
teaching-- or if
what they're teaching
is very specific
to their research--
you can tell that
they want to teach it
and they want you to
learn it because they're
very excited about it.
Then the student is probably
going to be more engaged.
NARRATOR: And before
any other quality,
students say they
want knowledge,
but they're also
confident you'll have it.
CAROL: I think I
personally trust
that MIT has selected fine
TAs to teach us the material.
NARRATOR: So on the
first day, rather
than trying to
impress the students,
stick with the simple
explanation of why you are
a good fit to teach the class.
GUOLONG: I'm a third year grad
student in the department of
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm working with Professor
Oppenheim, who is also
the lecturer of this class.
NARRATOR: Students also want
TAs to show self confidence.
CAROL: When I think
of confidence in a TA,
I think of someone who is
very-- they come off as, OK, I
know this material
better than you,
and I'm going to
teach it to you.
So often, I think TAs who speak
not super fast and just pretty
articulate and slower, so
that their point gets across,
usually I feel more
sure that they're pretty
good at explaining things.
BILLY: The speed you have when
you talk in a conversation,
just divide that by two.
And just because you're
nervous in front of people,
the speed will
increase either way.
So, speaking a little
bit more slowly
helps a lot because you
can also have the time
to think about
what you're saying,
and the audience and the
students you're speaking to
will have a better time
understanding, especially
if pronunciation or if
you have a certain accent.
NARRATOR: So, speed
makes a difference
in how students see you.
What about volume?
SHAWN: In a big
classroom, I definitely
have to remind myself
that I have to raise
my voice a little bit louder.
NARRATOR: Speaking
too quietly can also
give the impression
of nervousness.
GUOLONG: This week's
lecture focuses
on sampling rate conversion.
NARRATOR: A stronger
voice projects confidence
and commands attention.
GUOLONG: This week's
lecture focuses
on sampling rate conversion.
NARRATOR: Getting to
the classroom early
can also help you to feel
more confident, because you
can get to know the students
before you start teaching.
And planning ahead
not only makes
you feel more
confident, it also makes
students confident in you.
CAROL: So, I think
one TA that I had--
when I think of a user friendly
class, I think of his class,
because every day he had
his recitation planned
to the minute-- which
is pretty ridiculous--
but it actually was very
logical in a way that
helped the students learn.
So he would pretty much write
the agenda on the blackboard.
Like from minute
zero to minute five,
we're going to take a quiz.
And from minute
five to minute 10,
we're going to talk
about the quiz.
If they seem like
they're well organized--
they have their papers in
a nice, little folder--
I definitely look at that.
CHANDLER: Having
a real lesson plan
and showing that there's
going to productivity
in the recitations is important.
Having someone prepared
shows that they
were thinking about us
when we weren't in class.
NARRATOR: Finally, international
teaching assistants
also stress preparation
and planning
in their advice for a
successful first day.
SHAWN: As an international
teaching assistant,
we have some
disadvantages probably
compared to native speakers.
But if we are prepared,
if we show our enthusiasm
towards the subject,
I think the students
will feel them as well.
CARLA: Just be prepared.
That's what speaks scores about
you-- if you're very prepared.
MARZIEH: I went through all
the notes, all the books that
are related to the course.
And I tried to prepare
some good examples.
GUOLONG: I think for that
class, I did over preparation
that if I discussed
everything on my notebook,
it would take two hours
instead of one hour.
So I think never
running out of materials
seems another source
of my confidence.
CARLA: I should be
confident enough just
by the sake of being the TA.
You shouldn't be nervous
because you do know more
about the topic than they do.
MARZIEH: It was challenging,
but in a good way.
SHAWN: Get everything prepared.
Do your best.